メンバーシップの新着記事が届きました
noteで読む
エーアイが賢くなるほど儲かる、半導体の工程とその利益を得る企業は？
最近、ゆな先生のXのタイムラインは、相変わらずエーアイ半導体の話題で埋め尽くされている。
「半導体で7月は最悪だった」
「売った後に反発して最悪」
「そろそろ底値で狙いたい」
「地味にNvidiaも上がってきてる」
「売ったら反発し始めて終わった」
こんな投稿が毎日のように流れてくる。
ゆな先生のnoteでも、Nvidia、Broadcom、TSMC、SK Hynix、味の素、など、エーアイ半導体のサプライチェーンについては嫌というほど解説してきた。
この華やかなエーアイ半導体の世界において、今回の乱高下での影響が思いの外少なく乱高下の耐性が強く、
株は急激ではないが安定的に上がり、会社の業績も儲かり続けている工程と銘柄が存在
する。
それは、
テスト工程である。
半導体というものは、作って終わりではない。
出来上がったチップが本当に設計通りに動くのかを、1個1個、電気を流して検査しなければ出荷できない。
この地味の極みのような検査の仕事が、エーアイ時代に入ってとんでもないことになっているのだ。
その象徴が、日本の
アドバンテスト
という会社である。
アドバンテストは下落耐性が強い
半導体テスター（検査装置）
で世界シェアの過半を握るこの会社、エーアイブームが本格化して以降、業績の上方修正を連発し、売上高はついに1兆円規模に到達した。
営業利益率は4割を超え、四半期によっては5割に達する。
トヨタ自動車の営業利益率が10パーセント前後であることを考えれば、製造業でこの数字がいかに異常かわかるだろう。
株価はこの数年で何倍にもなり、日経平均を動かす銘柄としてファーストリテイリングやソフトバンクグループと並んで語られる存在にまでなった。
それなのに、「アドバンテストって何の会社?」と聞かれて即答できる日本人は、いまだに少ない。
半導体業界において、テストというのは長らく地味な脇役であった。
前工程のリソグラフィ（回路の焼き付け）には最先端の技術が詰まっていそうだし、リソグラフィ最大手のASMLのEUV露光装置は1台数百億円といった派手な話題には事欠かない。
いっぽうのテストは、出来上がったものを検査するだけの、言ってしまえばコストセンターである。
製造装置ではないのだ。
半導体メーカーからすれば、できることなら削りたい工程の筆頭であった。
しかし、株価から見るに、アドバンテストは過去5年で株価は約14倍、過去1年でも3倍である。
今回のかぶしきしじょう下落でも耐性が極めて強かった。
脇役が、超高性能エーアイ時代に入って主役級の扱いに変わりつつある。
チップを設計しているわけでもない。
チップを製造しているわけでもない。
出来上がったものを検査する、ただそれだけの装置を作っている会社が、なぜここまで儲かるのか。
エーアイはこれからも進化していく。
それと同時に、エーアイを動かす半導体も進化していく。
チップは巨大化し、積層され、チップレットという新しい構造へと変わりつつある。
テストは増えるのか、減るのか
半導体製造のテスト工程はこれからどうなるのだろうか。
「エーアイが賢くなれば、検査だってエーアイが効率化してくれるんだから、テストは減っていくんじゃないですか」
と思う読者もいるだろう。
実際、エーアイを使ってテストを効率化する取り組みはすでに始まっている。
半導体の設計にエーアイを用いて効率化する取り組みさえも始まっている。
いっぽうで、
「チップが複雑になるんだから、テストは増えるに決まってるでしょ」
という意見もあるだろう。
増えるのか、減るのか。
増えるなら何が増え、減るなら何が減るのか。
そして、その変化で利益を得るのはどの企業で、割を食うのはどの企業なのか。
先に種明かしをしてしまうと、テストは減らない。
減るどころか、爆発的に増えていく。
ただし、単純に量が増えるという話ではない。
増える場所と減る場所がはっきりと分かれ、テストという仕事の中身そのものが組み変わっていく。
そして、その組み変わりこそが、勝者と敗者を分けることになる。
そもそも半導体のテスト工程とは何か
本題に入る前に、まずは基礎のおさらいをしておこう。
ゆな先生のnote読者なら理解している人も多いと思うが、半導体の製造工程は、大きく
前工程と後工程
に分かれる。
半導体の前工程と後工程。
非常に長いプロセスをこなしていく。
前工程は、シリコンウエハの上に回路を焼き付けていく工程
である。
TSMCの巨大工場で、ASMLのEUV露光装置がナノメートル単位の回路を描いていく、あの華やかな世界である。
これがウエハーと呼ばれるもので、写真で見たことがある人もいると思う。
ウエハーとかウェハーとか、ウエハとか言うが、今回は文字数削減のために「ウエハ」と呼んでいく。
出典：wikipedia
1枚のウエハの上には、同じチップが数百個、碁盤の目のように並んで作られる。
この画像で見ればわかるように、円形のウエハの中に、同じようなチップが大量に並んでいるのがわかる。
このウエハー状態では、顧客には届けることは出来ない。
後工程は、そのウエハを1個1個のチップに切り分け、パッケージに封入して出荷できる製品として仕上げる工程
である。
いぜん解説した味の素のABF基板や、TSMCのCoWoSといった話は、すべてこの後工程の話であった。
では、テストはこの流れのどこにあるのか。
実は、1箇所ではない。
製造の流れの中に、なんどもなんども挟み込まれている。
さいしょの関所、ウエハテスト
さいしょの関門が、ウエハテストである。
プローブテストとも呼ばれる。
前工程が終わったウエハに対して、チップに切り分ける前の段階で、1個1個に電気を流して動作を確認する
このとき使われるのが、テスタと呼ばれる検査装置である。
株式投資家のテスタではなく、Testerのテスタである。
[EN]英語ではATE（Automated Test Equipment）という。
[/EN]
そしてテスタとチップの間をつなぐのが、
プローブカード
という治具である。
プローブカード。
出典：日本マイクロニクス
プローブカードには髪の毛より細い針が何千本、何万本と植えられている。
剣山のような形をしている。
この針の束をチップの電極に精密に接触させ、テスタから電気信号を送り込み、返ってきた信号が設計通りかを確認する。
プローバ・プローブカードの解説
人間でいえば健康診断の採血である。
針を刺して、中身が正常かどうかを調べる。
ここで不良と判定されたチップは、次の工程に進めない。
なぜウエハの段階でわざわざ検査するのかというと、不良品をそのままパッケージングしてしまうと、パッケージ代と組立代が丸ごと無駄になるから
である。
死んだチップに高級な衣装を着せても意味がない。
不良は、金をかける前に早く見つけるほど損害が小さい。
これはテスト工程の大原則なので覚えておいてほしい。
二度目の関門：ファイナルテスト
ウエハテストを通過したチップは切り分けられ、パッケージに封入される。
そして再び検査が待っている。
ファイナルテスト
である。
ファイナルテスト。
出典：United precision社
今度はパッケージ状態のチップをテストソケットに装着し、テスタで動作確認をする。
チップを1個ずつ自動でソケットに出し入れし、温度をかけたりもする装置をハンドラと呼ぶ。
テスタ、ハンドラ、ソケット
。
この三点セットでファイナルテストは行われる。
「ウエハの段階で検査したのに、なんでもう一回やるんですか。
二度手間じゃないですか」
と思う読者もいると思う。
だが、切り分けや組立の過程でチップが壊れることもあれば、パッケージに入れて初めて出る不具合もある。
高温や低温の環境でちゃんと動くかも、この段階で確認する。
パッケージ後のテストこそが、出荷前のさいごの砦なのである。
初期不良をあぶり出すバーンイン
さらに、用途によっては
バーンイン
という工程が加わる。
チップに高温と高めの電圧をかけて、わざと過酷な状態で長時間動かし続ける試験である。
バーンインテストの例
半導体には初期不良というものがある。
買った直後は動くのに、数週間、数ヶ月で壊れる個体が一定数存在するのだ。
家電でも何でも、買ってすぐ壊れるハズレを引いた経験のある読者はいるだろう。
あれである。
バーンインは、この初期不良になりそうな弱い個体を、出荷前に強制的にあぶり出して振り落とす工程である。
いわば圧迫面接だ。
負荷をかけてもへこたれない個体だけが、客先に出ていくことを許される。
サーバー用や車載用など、故障が許されない半導体ほど、このバーンインが念入りに行われる。
エーアイ用の半導体は1個数百万円になるものもある。
納入してから壊れたなどと言われたら信用問題になる。
本番さながらの実地試験のSLT
そして近年、存在感を急速に増しているのが
SLT、システムレベルテスト
である。
従来のテストは、テスタが作った試験用の信号パターンでチップを検査する。
いわば模擬試験である。
いっぽうの
SLTは、チップを実際の製品に近い環境に組み込み、本物のオーエスやソフトウェアを走らせて動作を確認
する。
本番さながらの実地試験だ。
ゲーセンでの運転では強いけど実際にサーキットを走行すると遅いということは十分ある。
映画「グランツーリスモ」では、プレイステーションの運転ゲームのグランツーリスモでは世界最強クラスだったが、実際の現場で運転してみると想定外のことが多くて苦労をするというシーンが多々出てくる。
実話に基づく映画で、結構面白かったのでおすすめである。
テスタの試験項目は全部パスするのに、実際のシステムに載せると誤動作するチップが存在する。
チップが複雑になればなるほど、この模擬試験と本番のギャップは広がっていく。
だからSLTという工程が新たに追加されてきたのである。
テストは査定の場でもある
ここまでをまとめると、半導体はウエハテスト、ファイナルテスト、必要に応じてバーンインやSLTと、何段階もの検査をくぐり抜けてようやく出荷される。
そしてテストには、良品と不良品を分ける以外に、もう一つ重要な役割がある。
選別、業界用語でいうビニングである。
同じ設計、同じラインで作ったチップでも、出来には個体差がある。
高いクロックで軽々と動く優等生もいれば、定格でしか動かない普通の子もいる。
テストでこの個体差を測定し、上位品は高いグレードの製品として高く売り、下位品は廉価グレードとして安く売る。
シーピーユーやジーピーユーに松竹梅のラインナップが存在するのは、実はこのビニングの結果であることが多い。
MacBookのMシリーズのチップで、「標準はジーピーユーコアが7個だが、お金を追加しグレードアップすると8個になりますよ」というものがあったりするが、これはビニングの結果である場合と、意図的に性能を落としている場合の2種類がある。
いずれにせよ、つまりテストとは、単なる出荷前検査ではなく、1個1個のチップの値札を決める査定の場でもあるのだ。
ただ、それでも半導体メーカーにとって、テストは長らくコストセンターであった。
テストをいくら頑張っても、チップの性能が上がるわけではない。
検査は1秒でも短く、1円でも安く。
テストエンジニアは常にそういう圧力にさらされてきた。
もっとも、ここまで説明した姿は、あくまでスマホやPC向けの普通の半導体の話である。
エーアイ半導体の世界では、この検査の風景が別次元のものへと変貌しつつある。
なぜエーアイチップは、テストをこれほどまでに爆発させるのだろう。
エーアイ半導体の進化がテストを爆発させる理由
エーアイ半導体の世界では、この風景が一変する。
どのくらい変わるかというと、
エーアイチップのテスト時間は従来のシーピーユーの数倍以上、テスト装置のコストは数倍以上
とも言われる。
しかも工程の数そのものが増えている。
アドバンテストの業績が爆発しているのは、半導体の生産数が増えたからというだけではなく、1個あたりのテストの量と単価が跳ね上がったから
なのである。
なぜそんなことになるのか。
理由は大きく4つある。
順番に見ていこう。
理由1　チップがデカくなりすぎた
まず単純な話から。
エーアイチップは、とにかく巨大である。
NvidiaのBlackwell世代のジーピーユーには、2000億個を超えるトランジスタが詰め込まれている。
一昔前のスマホ向けチップが100億個程度だったことを考えると、20倍である。
テストとは、要するにチップの中の回路が正しく動くかを確認する作業である。
検査すべき回路が20倍になれば、検査項目も検査時間もそれに応じて膨らんでいく。
一軒家の完成検査と、たわまん一棟の完成検査を考えてみてほしい。
一軒家なら、ドアの建て付けと水回りと電気系統を半日も見れば終わる。
だがたわまん一棟となると、全戸の内装に加えて、エレベーター、給水システム、非常用電源、共用部の設備まで、検査項目は膨大になり、何週間もかかる。
エーアイチップのテストで起きているのは、まさにこれである。
検査対象が一軒家からたわまんになった
のだ。
検査員の日当が同じでも、検査にかかる総額は跳ね上がる。
理由2　チップレットと積層が追加の検査を生む
2つ目の理由が、きょうの記事のだいじなポイントである。
チップの作り方そのものが変わったことで、これまで存在しなかった検査が生まれている。
いぜんの記事で解説した通り、最先端のエーアイチップはもはや1枚の板ではない。
ジーピーユーの演算ダイ、積層されたHBMメモリ、それらを載せるインターポーザといった複数の部品を、CoWoSのような先端パッケージング技術で精密に組み合わせた集合体である。
そして業界全体が、大きな1枚のチップを作る方式から、機能ごとに分割した小さなチップ（チップレット）を組み合わせる方式へと移行しつつある。
ここで問題になるのが、
組み合わせるという行為の難易度
である。
HBMメモリを思い出してほしい。
ディーラムのダイを8層、12層、16層と垂直に積み上げて作る、あの立体構造のメモリである。
今のところ、SK Hynix、Samsung、Micronしか作れない。
仮に、1枚のダイの良品率が95パーセントだとしよう。
95パーセントといえばかなり優秀な歩留まりに聞こえる。
だが、これを8枚積むとどうなるか。
0.95の8乗で、約66パーセント。
12枚積めば54パーセントまで落ちる。
つまり、
1枚1枚は"ほぼ"良品でも、無検査で積み上げると、完成品の3分の1から半分が不良品になる
のだ。
しかも積層後に1枚でも不良が見つかれば、残り11枚の良品ダイもろとも全部廃棄である。
組体操のピラミッドと同じである。
一人でもぐらつく子が混ざっていれば、ピラミッド全体が崩れる。
だから組む前に、全員の体調を完璧に確認しておかなければならない。
この、
積む前に完璧に選別された良品ダイのことを、業界ではKGD（Known Good Die）
と呼ぶ。
確かに良品だと分かっているダイ、という意味である。
従来のウエハテストは、後工程に不良品を流さない程度のふるい分けで良かった。
多少の見逃しがあっても、ファイナルテストで捕まえればよかったからだ。
だがチップレットと積層の時代には、そうはいかない。
1個の見逃しが、高価な部品の集合体を丸ごと道連れ
にする。
ウエハ段階のテストに要求される精度が、次元の違うレベルに引き上げられたのである。
実際、
KGD選別の精度を高めることで、8層スタックの良品率が66パーセントから96パーセントまで改善するというデータもある
テストは、もはや不良品を弾く関所ではない。
歩留まりを作り出す工程
になったのだ。
ただの最終検査ではなく、半導体製造工程の重要な位置を占めるに至った
さらに、工程の数も増えている。
HBMの場合、ウエハテスト、KGD選別、積層後のテスト、バーンイン、最終テストと5段階もの検査をくぐる。
普通のディーラムなら2段階程度で済んでいたものが、倍以上である。
チップレット構造のジーピーユーも同様で、個々のダイの検査、組み合わせた後の中間検査、パッケージ後の検査、そしてSLTと、検査ポイントがどんどん追加されていく。
「積む前に検査して、積んだ後にも検査して、さらにパッケージ後にも検査するんですか。
やりすぎでは」
と思うかもしれない。
だが、後の工程に進むほど部品の価値は積み上がっていくのだから、各段階の入り口で検査するのが最も損害が小さい。
高額な部品を組み合わせてエーアイ用の半導体は作られていく。
後でゴミを混ぜて全体がパアになったら、大損害である。
それならコストをかけて検査をしたほうがマシなのだ。
さっき書いた、
不良は金をかける前に見つけるほど安いという大原則
が、部品点数が増えたことで何重にも適用されるようになっただけの話である。
理由3　1200Wのマシンを検査する難易度
3つ目は、電力の問題である。
NvidiaのB200のTDP(ピーク時の発熱電力)は1200Wに達する。
電気ストーブの強モードと同じ熱を、ジーピーユーは手のひらサイズのパッケージから吐き出す怪物
である。
このモンスターマシンを検査するのは、並大抵のことではない。
テスト中、チップには実動作と同等の電力を流し込む必要がある
つまりテスト装置は、1個のチップに1200Wの電力を正確に供給しながら、発生する猛烈な熱を冷却し、チップの温度を精密にコントロールしなければならない。
温度管理が甘いと、本当は良品なのに熱で誤動作して不良と判定されたり、その逆が起きたりする。
体温計が壊れた健康診断など意味がないのと同じで、検査環境の温度制御はテストの生命線である。
昔のテストは、チップに小さな電気を流して反応を見る、いわば聴診器を当てる程度の作業だった。
今のエーアイチップのテストは、フルマラソンを走らせながら心電図と血圧と体温を測り続ける負荷試験である。
当然、それができる装置は複雑になり、高価になる。
プローブカードも、大電流と高温に耐えられる特注品が必要になり、1枚数千万円という世界になってきている。
理由4　データセンター「止まれない」問題
そして4つ目が、最も大きな用途の変化である。
諸君のスマホが月に1回フリーズしても、まあ許されるだろう。
イラッとするが、再起動すれば済む話である。
だが、エーアイデータセンターではそうはいかない。
大規模なエーアイの学習では、数万個のジーピーユーが一つのチームとして、数週間から数ヶ月にわたって連携し続ける。
そして、
たった1個のジーピーユーが故障すると、学習ジョブ全体が停止
する。
数万人の綱引きで、一人が転んだだけで全員が仕切り直しになるようなものだ。
これは机上の話ではない。
メタが公開した報告
によれば、1万6000個のジーピーユーを使ったLlama 3の学習では、54日間で400回以上も予期せぬ中断が発生し、その大半がハードウェア起因だったという。
おおよそ3時間に1回、どこかで何かが壊れていた計算である。
ジーピーユークラスタが巨大化すればするほど、どこかの1個が壊れる確率は上がっていく。
さらに厄介なのが、
サイレント・データ・コラプション、静かなデータ破損と呼ばれる現象
である。
これは、
チップが停止もエラー表示もせず、ただ計算結果だけを間違えるという、最悪の故障状態
である。
「はい！
この数字は絶対正確です！
」
と笑顔で報告してくる社員の数字が間違っているような感じだろうか。
グーグルやメタは数年前から、データセンターの何十万個というシーピーユーの中に、ごくまれに計算を静かに間違える個体が紛れ込んでいると報告してきた。
レジは正常に動いているように見えるのに、時々1円だけ多く打っている。
そんな店員が数万人に一人混ざっているのだ。
普通の業務なら気づかないかもしれない。
だがエーアイの学習では、この静かな嘘が数兆回の計算に混入し、モデルの品質を密かに蝕んでいく。
何週間もかけた学習が、たった1個の不誠実なチップのせいで台無しになる可能性すらある。
こういう個体は、従来の出荷テストをすり抜けてくる。
だからこそ、テストの網の目を細かくし、SLTのような本番さながらの試験を追加し、負荷をかけた状態での挙動まで検査するようになった。
1個数百万円のジーピーユーを買う顧客が、完璧な品質保証を要求するのは当然である。
そしてその品質保証のコストは、テスト工程が引き受けることになる。
コストセンターから戦略部門への変化
ここまでをまとめる。
チップの巨大化がテストの量を増やし、チップレットと積層が検査ポイントの数を増やし、高電力化がテスト装置の単価を引き上げ、信頼性要求がテストの深さを要求する。
量、回数、単価、深さ。
四拍子そろってテストは膨張している。
かつて、テストは削るべきコストだった。
今や、テストは歩留まりと品質を作り出す工程であり、テスト能力の不足がそのままエーアイ半導体の出荷数を制約するボトルネックにすらなっている。
どんなに前工程で立派なチップを焼いても、検査が追いつかなければ出荷できないからだ。
しかし、勘の良い読者はここでこう思うはずである。
「でもさ、ゆな先生。
エーアイがこれだけ賢くなってるんだから、その検査自体をエーアイに効率化させればいいじゃないですか」
非常に鋭い指摘である。
実は、その通りのことがすでに始まっている。
そしてそれは、テスト業界の勢力図を塗り替えかねない動きでもある。
エーアイ自身がテストをどう変えるのかも見ていこう。
エーアイ自身がテストを変えるという話
「検査自体をエーアイに効率化させればいいじゃないですか」
という疑問は、確かにゆな先生も持っていた。
結論から言えば、エーアイによるテストの効率化はすでに量産現場で始まっている
しかし、それでもテストの総量は減らない
むしろ効率化が進むほどテストは増えるという、一見矛盾した現象が起きる。
この構造を理解しないと、後工程の勝ち組と負け組を見分けられなくなる。
全員に同じ検査をするのは、必要か？
まず、従来のテストがどれだけ大雑把だったかを知ってほしい。
これまでの半導体テストは、基本的に全数一律であった。
同じ品種のチップには、優等生にも劣等生にも、まったく同じテストプログラムを頭から尻まで流す。
ウエハの真ん中で作られた出来の良いチップにも、外周部で作られた怪しいチップにも、同じ検査を同じ時間だけかける。
空港の保安検査で言えば、乗客全員に同じ時間のボディチェックをしているようなものである。
明らかに怪しい人物も、毎週乗っている常連のビジネスマンも、一律同じ扱い。
安全ではあるが、効率は悪い。
だが実際には、チップの出来にはウエハ上の位置や製造ロットによって明確な傾向がある。
前工程の装置データ、ウエハ上の座標、周囲のチップの検査結果。
こうした情報を突き合わせれば、このチップは怪しい、このチップはまず大丈夫、という予測がかなりの精度で立つのだ。
そこで登場したのが、
アダプティブテスト
という考え方である。
予測したチップ1個1個のリスクに応じて、テストの中身を動的に変える。
危なそうな個体は徹底的に検査し、優良と予測される個体は検査を簡略化する。
保安検査で言えば、経験上ヤバそうな雰囲気のやつには検査を強化し、よく見るビジネスマンは軽い検査で済ます。
リスクベースで検査の濃淡をつけるやり方である。
この、個体ごとの判断を瞬時に下す頭脳として、
機械学習
が使われ始めた。
検査装置メーカーとNvidiaが手を組んだ
象徴的な出来事が2025年に起きている。
検査メーカーの大手・アドバンテストが、Nvidiaのエーアイ技術を自社のテスト基盤に組み込むと発表したのだ。
アドバンテストは
ACS RTDI
というデータ基盤を持っている。
世界中の量産現場のテスタから吐き出される膨大な測定データを、リアルタイムに収集・解析する仕組みである。
ここにNvidiaの機械学習を組み合わせ、テストの流れをその場その場でエーアイが最適化する。
そしてこの仕組みは、ほかならぬNvidia自身のBlackwellおよび次世代チップの量産テストに採用された。
つまり、Nvidiaのエーアイチップを検査するために、Nvidiaのエーアイが使われ、そのエーアイはNvidiaのジーピーユーの上で動いている。
エーアイが自分の弟や妹の健康診断をしている、と考えると味わい深い構図である。
エーアイによる効率化の中身は、アダプティブテストだけではない。
テストプログラムの開発支援もある。
巨大なチップのテストプログラムかいはつは、優秀なエンジニアが何ヶ月もかける職人仕事だったが、このいちぶをエーアイが肩代わりし始めている。
テスタ自体の予知保全もそうだ。
装置の故障を事前に察知して止まる前に手を打てば、高価なテスタの稼働率が上がる。
不良解析も、膨大な測定データからエーアイが不良の癖を見つけ出し、前工程へフィードバックして歩留まり改善を早める。
1個あたりのテスト時間を削り、装置を遊ばせず、人手のかかる仕事を自動化する。
どれも、テストのコストを引き下げる方向に働く技術である。
「ほら、やっぱりテストは減るんじゃないですか。
効率化されるってことは、テスタの台数も少なくて済むようになるってことでしょう」
そう思うのが普通だろう。
だが、意外とそうでもない。
効率化するほど消費が増える不思議
19世紀のイギリスに、ジェボンズという経済学者がいた。
ゆな先生がよく引用する経済学者である。
彼は、蒸気機関の燃費が改善すれば石炭の消費は減るはずだという常識に対して、逆のことを指摘した。
「効率が上がって石炭を使うコストが下がった結果、蒸気機関はあらゆる場所で使われるようになり、石炭の総消費量はむしろ爆発的に増える」と説いた。
ジェボンズのパラドックスと呼ばれる話で、実際に石炭の消費量は増えた。
エーアイの推論コストでも同じことが起きているのは、諸君も実感している通りである。
1トークンあたりの推論コストはこの数年で劇的に下がったし、無料で使えるエーアイも増えてきたが、安くなったからこそ皆がエーアイを使い倒すようになり、計算じゅようの総量は天文学的に膨らんだ。
テストでも、まったく同じことが起きる。
考えてみてほしい。
エーアイによる効率化でテスト時間が2割削れたとする。
半導体メーカーはその浮いた2割で何をするか。
テスタを2割減らして経費を節約する、とはならないのである。
浮いた時間とコストは、これまで時間の制約で諦めていた、より深い検査に振り向けられる
先ほど述べた通り、エーアイ半導体の顧客が要求する品質水準はインフレし続けている。
静かに嘘をつくチップを1個でも出荷すれば、数百億円のデータセンターが疑心暗鬼に陥る世界である。
検査を深くする動機は、事実上無限にあるのだ。
つまり、
エーアイによるテスト効率化は、テストを減らす技術ではない。
同じコストで、より深く、より賢く検査するための技術
である。
保安検査の例えで言えば、検査が効率化されたから検査員を減らすのではなく、同じ人数でより精密な検査体制を敷くのである。
1人でもテロリストが混ざっていたら数百人の命が失われるのだから。
その1人を探し出すために、できるだけ時間をセーブしながらより高度な検査をしていくことになる。
減るものと増えるもの
エーアイとエーアイ半導体の進化によって、テスト工程で減るものと増えるものは、はっきり分かれる。
減るもの。
それは、意味の薄い一律テストであり、人手に頼ったテストプログラムかいはつの工数であり、不良解析にかかる時間であり、装置の遊び時間である。
要するに、テストの中の無駄と単純作業が削られていく。
増えるもの。
それは、検査ポイントの数（KGD選別、積層後検査、SLT）であり、1個あたりに求められる検査の深さであり、高電力・高精度対応の装置や治具の単価であり、そして
テストが生み出すデータの量と価値
である。
特にさいごのデータの話は強調しておきたい。
テスタは、チップ1個を検査するたびに膨大な測定データを吐き出す。
かつては合否判定に使われて捨てられていたこのデータが、エーアイと機械学習が使える時代には歩留まり改善と品質予測のための宝の山に変わった。
テスタはもはや単なる検査ではなく、工場全体の改善に情報を送り込むセンサー・アドバイザーになりつつあるのだ。
テストという仕事は、単純な合否判定から、データを使った品質の作り込みへと移っていく。
テストのデータの質と量は、製品開発や製造工程の改善に大きな意味をもたらす。
この変化についていけるテスタ企業とそうではない企業は、当然明暗は分かれる。
さて、構造の話はここまでで出揃った。
いよいよ本題である。
この地殻変動で、実際に利益を得るのはどの企業なのか。
テスト工程のサプライチェーンを、川上から川下まで見ていこう。
利益を得る企業はどこか
ゴールドラッシュで儲かったのは、金を掘る鉱夫ではなくツルハシとジーンズを売った商人だったという話は、ゆな先生のnoteでなんどもしてきた。
エーアイというゴールドラッシュにおけるツルハシがNvidiaのジーピーユーであり、だからNvidiaに全世界のマネーが群がった。
では、テスト工程の企業たちは何者なのか。
彼らは、ツルハシの検品屋である。
鉱夫に渡す前のツルハシを1本1本検品し、振るった瞬間に柄が折れる不良品を弾き、切れ味を査定して値札を付ける。
ツルハシが高級化し、複雑化し、1本の不良が鉱山全体を止めるようになった今、検品屋の言い値は上がり続けている。
そして面白いことに、この検品業界は、掘る側のNvidia対AMDのような派手な競争があまりない。
レイヤーごとに、ほぼ寡占が完成しているのである。
テスタ本体
まず頂点に立つのが、テスタそのものを作る企業である。
ここは世界的に見て、
日本のアドバンテストと米国のTeradyneによる事実上の複占市場(2社独占市場)
になっている。
高性能チップ向けのSoCテスタでは、
アドバンテスト
が世界シェアの過半を握る。
特にエーアイ向けジーピーユーやHBMメモリのテストでは圧倒的で、Nvidia、TSMC、SK Hynixといった主役級の企業が、こぞってアドバンテストのテスタを並べている。
なぜ2社しか残っていないのかというと、テスタというのは、装置を作れば売れるという世界ではないからである。
数千億個のトランジスタを持つチップに、正確な信号を送り、ナノ秒単位で応答を測り、1000Wの電力を供給しながら温度を制御する。
このハードウェアだけでも変態的な技術の塊だが、本当の参入障壁はその上に載るソフトウェアと実績である。
半導体メーカーは、チップの設計ごとにテストプログラムを開発し、それを量産ラインのテスタに載せてなんねんも使い続ける。
一度アドバンテストのプラットフォームでテスト環境を構築したら、他社に乗り換えるには膨大な検証をやり直さなければならない。
NvidiaのCUDAが築いた参入障壁とよく似た構造が、テストの世界にもあるのだ。
ハードウェアで競合を排除するには、ソフトウェアの優秀さが常に必要
である。
その結果がどうなったかだが、アドバンテストの売上高は1兆円規模に達し、営業利益率は40パーセントを超え、四半期によっては50パーセントに達した。
装置産業でこの利益率は、
独占的な価格決定権を持っている
証拠に他ならない。
しかも同社は、テスタを売って終わりの商売から脱却しつつある。
前章で触れたACSというデータ基盤、SLT装置、テストソケットの名門Essaiの買収、インターフェースボード企業の買収と、テスト工程の周辺をまるごと囲い込みに来ている。
検品屋の親玉が、検品に使う道具一式と検品データの帳簿まで押さえに来ているのである。
いっぽうのTeradyneも、エーアイブームの恩恵は受けている。
ただし同社は協働ロボット事業なども抱える多角化企業であり、エーアイテストへの集中度ではアドバンテストに軍配が上がる。
しじょうが2社の複占である以上、どちらも沈みはしないが、
エーアイ特需の濃度が濃いのはアドバンテスト側
だと考えてよい。
テスタしじょうでは、ゆな先生はアドバンテストが圧倒的だと思っているし、今回の7月の下落での耐性をみて、保有銘柄に入れている。
プローブカードとソケット
テスタの次に注目すべきが、チップと装置の間をつなぐ治具のレイヤーである。
ここに、投資家として見逃せない特徴がある。
治具は消耗品であり、しかもチップの設計ごとの専用品
なのだ。
先ほど書いたプローブカードのような、何万本もの微細な針でチップの電極に接触する、あの精密治具である。
プローブカードは、チップの電極配置に合わせて設計される完全な特注品である。
つまり、新しいチップが出るたびに新しいカードが必要になる。
さらに針は物理的に接触を繰り返すため摩耗し、定期的な交換や補修が発生する。
テスタが10年使える耐久財なのに対し、プローブカードは新製品のたびに、そして消耗のたびに発注が来る。
半導体メーカーが新しいエーアイチップを開発すればするほど、自動的に売上が積み上がるリピートビジネスなのである。
このしじょうで世界首位に立つのが
米国のFormFactor
であり、日本勢では
日本マイクロニクス
日本電子材料
が続く。
特に日本マイクロニクスは、この数年で最も劇的に化けた銘柄の一つである。
同社はメモリ向けプローブカードに強く、HBMブームの恩恵を大きく受けた。
先ほど書いた通り、HBMはKGD選別のためにウエハ段階で徹底的に検査され、積層のたびにまた検査される。
検査回数が倍増するということは、プローブカードの消費量も跳ね上がるということである。
おまけにHBM向けカードは大電流・高温対応の高難度品で、単価も高い。
数量と単価が同時に上がるのだから、業績が爆発しないわけがなかった。
株価は数年で10倍近くに達し、気づいた投資家とそうでない投資家の明暗をくっきり分けた。
ファイナルテストで使うテストソケットも同じ構造である。
山一電機やエンプラス、韓国のLeenoやISCといった企業が主なプレーヤーだが、こちらもチップのパッケージごとの専用品であり、1200W級のチップに対応できる高性能ソケットは単価が上がり続けている。
ファイナルテストは回数は単純に製造数に比例するから、途中のテストの検査回数の増加の恩恵は受けにくい傾向がある。
これら消耗品を販売する企業は、派手さはないが、検査機器本体装置よりも業績の弾性は大きいことすらある。
カミソリ本体より替え刃で儲けるジレットモデルである。
安定的に刃は売れ続ける。
周辺装置、プローバとバーンインと温度制御
テスタとプローブカードだけでは、ウエハテストはできない。
ウエハをミクロン単位の精度で動かし、針に正確に押し当てる装置、プローバが必要である。
このプローバしじょうは、
東京精密
東京エレクトロン
の日本勢2社でほぼ寡占している。
地味な装置だが、ウエハテストの回数が増えれば当然プローバの稼働も需要も増える。
バーンイン関連も面白い。
初期不良をあぶり出す圧迫面接の工程だが、エーアイサーバー向けチップは故障が許されないため、バーンインの対象と時間が拡大する方向にある。
環境試験装置の老舗である
エスペック
や、ウエハレベルでバーンインを行う技術を持つ米国の
[EN]Aehr Test Systems[/EN]
などが、この流れの受け皿になる。
Aehr Test Systemsは株価はこの1年で5倍以上になった。
そして忘れてはならないのが温度制御である。
1200Wのチップを検査中に一定温度に保つ技術は、それ自体が高度な専門領域であり、テスタ本体と同じくらい重要になってきている。
アドバンテストがこの領域の技術を武器にHBMテストを制していることは、すでに述べた通りである。
テスト受託
ここまでは装置と治具の話だったが、テストという作業そのものを請け負う商売もある。
OSATと呼ばれる後工程受託企業のテスト事業、およびテスト専業の受託企業である。
この領域で象徴的なのが、台湾の
KYEC
京元電子
である。
同社はテスト受託の専業企業だが、Nvidiaのエーアイ向けジーピーユーのテストを大量に請け負っていることで一躍脚光を浴びた。
Nvidiaは自前のテスト工場など持っていない。
TSMCが焼いたチップは、台湾のテスト受託企業の工場でアドバンテストのテスタにかけられ、選別されてから世界へ出荷されていく。
テスト時間が3倍になるということは、受託企業の課金時間も3倍になるということであり、KYECの業績と株価はエーアイブームとともに急騰した。
株価はこの1年で+80パーセント、この5年では約5倍である。
Amkor
ASE
といった大手OSATも、テストサービスの比重を高めている。
チップレット時代の中間検査やSLTは、組立と検査を一体で請け負えるOSATにとって、単価を上げる絶好の口実になるからである。
我が国は半導体製造工場があまりないので、この分野は弱い。
データ関連
さいごに、まだきぼは小さいが将来の主戦場になるレイヤーに触れておく。
テストデータの解析ソフトウェア
である。
先述の通り、
テスタは検査のたびに膨大なデータを吐き出し、それが歩留まり改善の宝の山
になる。
この宝の山を掘るソフトウェアを提供するのが、米国の
PDF Solutions
のような解析専業企業であり、そして
ACSを擁するアドバンテスト自身
である。
PDF Solutionsは株価は1年で2.5倍になっている。
装置は一度売れば終わりだが、データ解析はサブスクリプションで課金し続けられる。
検品屋の帳簿屋・データ屋だが、これから高い利益率を手にする可能性がある。
ここは規模より方向性に注目しておくべきレイヤーである。
勝ち組に共通する3つの型
テスト膨張の恩恵を受ける企業には、共通する型がある。
(1)寡占によって複雑化をそのまま単価に転嫁できること。
(2)消耗品やリピート性のある収益構造を持つこと。
(3)装置だけでなくデータやソフトウェアへ商売を広げていること。
アドバンテストはこの3つをすべて満たす優等生
であり、プローブカード勢は第二の型の純度が高く、テスト受託勢はテスト時間の増加に正比例して稼ぐ。
「なるほど、ゆな先生。
ではテスト関連なら何を買っても儲かるんですね」
と思った読者は、少し気が早い。
テストの膨張は全員を潤すわけではない。
損をする企業
ここまで読むと、テスト業界全体がバラ色に見えるかもしれない。
だが、テストしじょうが過去最大になるという話は、あくまで市場全体を足し合わせた話であって、個別企業では利益を得ている会社ばかりではない。
エーアイは突然出現した太陽みたいなもので、太陽に近い惑星は激アツなのだが、遠い冥王星みたいな場所にいる企業にとっては激アツどころか全く関係ないのだ。
エーアイに縁のないテスト装置は不況
意外に思うかもしれないが、テスタしじょうはエーアイが登場する2023年いぜんは、ダウンサイクルの真っ只中にあった。
スマホ、家電、産業機器、車載。
コロナ禍でじゅようを先食いしたこのような業種では、こうした一般向け半導体のじゅようが低迷し、テスタへの投資も凍りついていたのである。
その氷河期の中で、エーアイ向けだけが桁違いの売上増加を突如始めたというのが正しい。
つまり、エーアイ向けチップのテストに食い込めていない装置メーカーにとって、この好況は他人の祭りである。
民生向けの汎用テスタやミドルレンジのテスタは、技術的な参入障壁が相対的に低く、価格競争に陥りやすい。
高級ツルハシの検品は2社しかできないが、普通のスコップの検品なら誰でもできるからである。
検品業界の中でも、どの道具を検品しているかで天国と地獄が分かれているのだ。
複占の一角であるTeradyneですら、かつてスマホ向け（つまりアップル向け）の比重が高かった時期には、コロナ禍のスマホバブルの反動を受けたスマホしじょうの停滞をもろに食らって苦しんだ。
どのチップのテストを握っているか。
テスト関連銘柄を見るときは、社名ではなく顧客の顔ぶれを見なければならない。
そして、その冷えているローエンドしじょうに、中国の影がちらついている。
BYDやCATLの記事で解説してきたてんかい、多くの家電業界や自動車業界でも起きてきたようなことが発生し始めている。
中国は半導体国産化の国策のもと、テスタの内製化も猛烈に進めており、
華峰測控（Accotest）
長川科技
といった中国テスタメーカーが、アナログやパワー半導体向けといったローエンド領域から着実にシェアを奪い始めているのだ。
最先端のエーアイ向けテスタは、まだ彼らの手に負える領域ではないのだが、BYDもさいしょは安物のバッテリーからだったし、中国EVもさいしょは誰にも相手にされていなかった。
ローエンドで量をこなし、稼いだ金で技術の階段を登ってくるのが製造大国。
中国の必勝パターンである。
厄介なのが、米中対立の輸出規制である。
先端半導体の対中規制が強化されるたびに、テスト装置も規制対象になる。
日本のテスト関連企業にとって中国は長らく大きなしじょうであっただけに、ハイエンドは規制で売れず、ローエンドは国産勢に奪われるという挟み撃ちの構図は、じわじわと効いてくる。
中国売上比率の高いテスト関連企業は、この点を割り引いて見る必要がある。
こんごの中国のエーアイ発展には注意が必要である。
中国が自前で半導体を作れるようになり、エーアイも世界を席巻すると、西側のテスタの伸びも落ちていく。
こんご数年以内には起きないだろうが、5年10年単位では要注意である。
エーアイに蝕まれる企業
先ほど、エーアイによる効率化はテストを減らさないと述べた。
ただしあれは、
最先端チップの話
である。
ミドルレンジ以下では話は変わってくる。
機械学習によるアダプティブテストの本質は、無駄な検査を削ることである。
最先端チップでは削った分がより深い検査に再投資されるからテストは減らないが、成熟したレガシー品種ではそうはならない。
なんねんも作り続けて製造が安定した品種は、エーアイで最適化すればテスト時間を素直に削減できるし、削減した分を品質に再投資する動機も乏しい
枯れた品種の検査は、純粋に短く、安くなっていくのだ。
これが誰を直撃するかというと、レガシー品種のテストを時間貸しで請け負ってきた受託企業である。
自動車向けの半導体など、求められるスペックが低いものは、苦しくなる。
テスト受託はテスタの稼働時間で課金する商売だから、顧客がエーアイで検査時間を3割削れば、売上も3割消える。
先ほどテスト受託を勝ち組に挙げたが、あれはエーアイ向けの最先端テストを握っている場合の話であり、レガシー中心の受託企業にはむしろ逆風が吹く。
また、静かに進むのが人の仕事の置き換えである。
テストプログラムかいはつは、長らく専門エンジニアの職人芸であり、その工数を請け負うエンジニアリングサービスや人材ビジネスが存在してきた。
エーアイがプログラム開発や不良解析の下働きを担うようになれば、この種の労働集約的な商売は確実に細っていく。
検品のノウハウそのものが、検品エーアイに吸い上げられていくのである。
嫌な話であるが、避けられない。
単機能の会社が抱えるリスク
テスト工程の内部でも、金の流れる場所が移動するリスクがある。
象徴がSLTである。
本番さながらの実地試験であるSLTは、実は1台あたりの装置としては従来型のハイエンドテスタより安価に構成でき、そのかわり大量に並列で並べる。
つまりSLTの拡大は、超高級なテスタの検査時間のいちぶを、比較的安価な装置の集団に肩代わりさせる動きでもあるのだ。
高価な模擬試験を短縮し、安い実地試験に置き換える。
半導体メーカーがテストコスト削減のためにこの配分を進めれば、ハイエンドテスタ一本足の企業は、成長のいちぶを自分で食われることになる。
アドバンテストがSLT企業やソケット企業を次々に買収してきたのは、この工程間シフトがどちらに転んでも儲かる布陣を敷くためだと、ゆな先生は見ている。
逆に言えば、単機能・単工程しか持たない中堅装置メーカーは、テスト膨張の恩恵を受けながらも、金の流れる場所が半歩ずれただけで置き去りにされる危うさを抱えている。
コストを払わされる側
さいごに、忘れられがちな敗者を挙げておこう。
テスト費用を払う側、つまり半導体メーカー自身である。
チップの製造原価に占めるテストコストの比率は、かつては数％程度と言われてきた。
それがエーアイチップでは、テスト時間3倍、工程数の増加、治具の高額化が積み重なり、原価に占める検査の割合が着実に膨らんでいる。
Nvidiaのように粗利率7割の会社なら、検査代など誤差である。
だが、粗利の薄い民生チップや、価格転嫁力のない中堅ファブレスにとって、膨らむ検査代は利益を直接削り取る重荷になる。
品質要求だけは一丁前にエーアイ水準へ引き上げられ、しかし売値は上げられない。
そういう板挟みのチップメーカーが、これから静かに増えていく。
検品屋が儲かるということは、裏を返せば、誰かが検品代を払い続けているということなのである。
勝ち組のリスク
さいごに一つ、勝ち組にすら共通するリスクを指摘しておかなければフェアではないだろう。
テスト業界の業績は、結局のところエーアイインフラへのせつびとうしに連動している。
そしてゆな先生が繰り返し書いてきた通り、半導体にはシリコンサイクルという宿命がある。
もしエーアイデータセンター投資に調整が来れば、装置の発注は真っ先に削られる。
テスタは景気の川下ではなく、川上にいる商売
なのだ。
アドバンテストや日本マイクロニクスの株価には、すでに相当な期待が織り込まれている。
構造が正しくても、買値が高すぎれば投資としては報われない。
買う時は価格に要注意である。
終わりに
今回の記事では、エーアイとエーアイ半導体の進化がテスト工程をどう変えるのかを、川上から川下まで解説してきた。
20000文字に達してしまったので、ここまで頑張って読んだ人は「読んだよ」とでもコメントを頂きたい。
だれが読んだのか見てみたい。
結局、テストは減らない。
増える
チップの巨大化が検査の量を増やし、チップレットと積層が検査の回数を増やし、高電力化が装置の単価を引き上げ、データセンターの信頼性要求が検査の深さを引き上げる。
エーアイによる効率化は進むが、それは無駄を削って浮いた分をより深い検査に再投資するための技術であり、テストの総量はむしろ膨らんでいく。
ただし、負け組も存在する
金が流れ込むのは、エーアイ向けの最先端テストを握る寡占企業と、チップの世代交代のたびに発注が湧いてくる消耗品ビジネスである。
いっぽうで、エーアイと縁のない汎用テスト、レガシー品種の時間貸し、人手に頼った職人仕事は、効率化と中国勢の追い上げで厳しい立場に追いやられていく。
テスト業界を買えばいいというわけでもないのだ。
世間のニュースやSNSは、きょうもアンソロピックとオープンエーアイとグーグルと、中国勢のエーアイモデルの賢さ比べと、Nvidiaなどばかりに注目が集まっている。
それはそれで楽しいのだが、我々投資家が見るべきは、その裏側で誰が確実に、高い利益率で、キャッシュを吸い上げ続けているかである。
考えてみれば、テスト工程というのは実に美しいポジションにいる。
エーアイの覇権をオープンエーアイが取ろうがグーグルが取ろうがアンソロピックが取ろうが、彼らの使うチップは必ず検査される。
ジーピーユーが勝とうがティーピーユーのようなASICが勝とうが、どちらも検査される。
チップレットが主流になれば検査ポイントが増え、歩留まりが悪化すれば選別が厳しくなり、品質事故が起きれば検査はさらに深くなる。
技術の勝敗に賭けず、技術の複雑化そのものに賭ける。
これはアンソロピックの記事で書いた、どのエーアイが勝ってもインフラ利用料はグーグルに落ちるという構図の、さらに一段裏側にある構図である。
この美しい構造は、別に秘密でもなんでもなく、アドバンテストの株価は日経平均を左右する水準まで買われ、日本マイクロニクスは数年で10倍になった。
構造に気づくのが早かった投資家は、すでにたっぷり報われている。
今から乗る者は、正しい構造を高い値段で買うことになるのかもしれないし、正しい構造を成長を見込んだ意外と安い値段で買うことになるかもしれないし、それはまだわからない。
そしてテスタはせつびとうしの商売である以上、シリコンサイクルからは逃れられない。
エーアイインフラ投資が一服すれば、業績と株価は容赦なく調整する日が来る。
調整したタイミングで、今日解説した構造を思い出してほしい。
テストの膨張は景気の波ではなく、チップの物理と品質要求がもたらす不可逆の潮流であって、エーアイが進化すればするほど嫌でも増加していく流れである。
ただの株価の波で株価が沈んだとき、潮流を理解している者だけが安く拾えるのだ。
エーアイが拡大すればするほど、嫌でもじゅようは増える。
きょうは、半導体を1個作るという行為の中で、削られ、嫌われ、コスト扱いされてきた検査という仕事が、いつの間にか歩留まりを作り、品質を保証し、出荷数まで左右する主役級に化けていたという話であった。
そしてアドバンテストという会社がその中心にいることを理解してもらった。
この記事が諸君らのポートフォリオを見直す一つの視座となれば幸いである。
皆の投資の成功を祈る。
ゆな先生より
スキする
コメントする
メンバーシップ
ゆな先生経済日記
プラン
ゆな先生日記　基本プラン
ゆな先生 さん
億り人の投資家かつしがない労働者です
さいきんの記事を見る
ヘルプ /
利用規約
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。